A familiar staff, a wizard's past mistakes,
and a minotaur in the Big Apple?
These are the little things you may have missed
in the new trailer for "Shazam: Fury of the Gods."
We know that Shazam's back to save the day
in "Fury of the Gods," but who exactly is
the big bad of the sequel?
Just going by the cast list, it's easy to
assume that Helen Mirren's Hespera is the
film's main villain.
Still, looking at the trailer, Hespera's role
kind of seems closer to a DCU equivalent to
the MCU's Odin— a powerful figure who's
done a bunch of awful stuff in the past, but
generally takes a more advisory role to their
younger proteges by the time the movie has started.
"You are very menacing."
Lucy Liu's Kalypso, on the other hand, is
another thing entirely.
She's the one who makes the best ominous poses,
and demolishes sports stadiums with her monstrous
green thumb.
And that's not even to mention the fact that
she's the one with the cool, dark costume.
Oh, and she's riding an actual dragon.
We don't know yet whether Kalypso is going
to be the secret power behind the throne or
just a very imposing lackey to Mirren's Hespera,
but either way, it's great to see Lucy Liu
back on the big screen in a big way.
One of the most eye-catching visual elements
of the "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods" trailers comes in the form
of a magical staff brimming with blue energy.
At different points in the trailer, viewers
can see both the villains and the hero all
using the staff during various big blowout
battles.
However, it seems that none of these characters
are actually the true owner of the weapon.
By all accounts, the staff actually belongs
to The Wizard Shazam himself.
Viewers of the original "Shazam!"
may recall that The Wizard uses what is presumably
the exact same staff to grant Billy his powers.
And speaking of Billy's powers, it's not looking
too good for the Big Red Cheese.
"The Daughters of Atlas are coming to hunt
us."
Based on the newest trailer, it seems like
those fearsome daughters have the perfect
weapon to do so.
In one moment in the trailer, Mary Marvel
is forcibly transformed back into her mortal
form by the staff, losing the one thing that
gives her a fighting chance against the bad guys.
While the idea of superheroes losing their
powers isn't necessarily novel, it'll be interesting
to see how the Shazam family takes on this
adversity.
Both trailers show that everyone is having
a great time with their new abilities, so
losing the powers they've come to rely on
might be a big blow to the Marvel family.
But it's not all doom and gloom for Shazam
fans.
Most excitingly, it seems like The Wizard
may have a far more prominent role than he
had in the first film.
While he primarily served as a mentor figure
and the cause of Billy's powers, the new trailer
makes it seem like the Daughters of Atlas
have a particular ax to grind against the
kindly Wizard.
Early in the trailer, Hespera is seen cursing
Batson and his friends from one side of a
prison door.
"Children stole the power of the gods.
You ripped it from our father's core."
While we don't see who she's talking to, there's
a high chance that it's The Wizard, who is
later seen blowing gold dust out of a window
while seemingly trapped in a cell.
Are his past sins coming back to haunt him?
Will he have enough power to help his champion
win the day?
Maybe not, especially given that his trusty
staff is being passed around like a mystical
hot potato.
We also know from a previous teaser that there
will be some new mythical creatures introduced
to Billy Batson's world in "Fury of the Gods."
A herd of black unicorns and a craggy-looking
dragon that breathes blue fire were the two
types of beasties on display in our first
look at the upcoming movie.
But the film's second trailer adds more creatures
to the mix.
There appears to be a chimera tearing apart
New York City during one of the teaser's most
heart-stopping moments.
Also briefly visible is a black minotaur-like
figure wreaking havoc in the big city.
While the dragons appear to be under the full
control of Kalypso and Hespera, and the unicorns
seem to have been tamed by Billy and his siblings,
it's anybody's guess how the other mythic
creatures get involved in the action.
Still, it definitely appears that "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods" is going to have fun with
the mythological aspect of Billy's roots when
the movie takes off on March 17.